I started out in t side
but where I went next
is classified clever advertising has
helped to promote Royal Navy careers but
defense sources say there's been a
serious drop in recruitment over the
past 18 months
left unresolved it could impact the UK's
ability to fight at Sea an even man its
nuclear deterrent submarines
One Source claimed the Royal Navy is
witnessing the general collapse of
recruitment
as the smallest service Workforce wise
with some truly unique trades connected
mainly to submarines failure in
recruitment will have strategic
implications at some point in the near
future
a former officer said recruitment is a
problem facing all navies with young
people less willing to listen to
Authority or be disconnected from their
phones while at Sea I'm really worried
because I think it takes such a long
time to fix there is no easy fix
otherwise it would probably have been
fixed by now
yet defense sources say the Royal Navy
is also dealing with its own challenges
to attract people to HMS rally the
training base for enlisted recruits as
well as officer training at Dartmouth
the problem they say is in part because
of an exodus of recruitment staff over
concerns about job security amid a plan
to bring in a new recruitment program
official figures show all three services
are struggling with recruitment but the
Navy is performing the worst
intake in the 12 months to March 2023
plunged 22.1 percent for the Royal Navy
and the Royal Marines compared with the
year earlier
for the Army it was down 14.6 percent
and it dropped 16.6 for the Royal Air
Force
unofficial figures seen by Sky News
reveal that in May there were only 109
recruits out of a maximum capacity of
375 at HMS rally
the head of the royal Navy has said he's
in a war for talent to attract young
people to join his service but if his
own recruitment system isn't working
properly he's fighting that fight
effectively with one hand behind his
back and if he can't get the people in
it means he's going to struggle to man
his ships and his submarines
spokesperson said the Royal Navy has
enough trained Personnel to meet all of
its operational commitments and it's
untrue to say there is a collapse in
recruitment we are experiencing the same
challenges as every employer in the UK
and are competing for people against a
national shortage
Sky News understands an emergency
meeting if the Navy Board was held last
month to discuss the recruitment crisis
Chiefs all too aware of the need to
ensure many more people are made in the
Royal Navy Deborah Haynes Sky News